a target in a bizarre murder for hire
plot in Texas is breaking her silence
about the case
Megan veritas took the stand yesterday
in the trial of her ex-boyfriend Leon
Jacob in emotional testimony she
described how these photos were staged
as part of an elaborate police sting to
disrupt the plot 48 hours correspondent
Peter Van Zant has been investigating
this story for nearly a year
Peter good morning hey good morning
prosecutors believe dr. Leon Jacob hired
a hitman to kill his ex-girlfriend megan
vera cos she had accused him of assault
and stalking after their breakup charges
that threatened to end his medical
career well yesterday we heard her side
of the story for the first time I was
crying and really upset
Megan veritas described in startling
detail what it was like to pose for
these photos meant to trick her
ex-boyfriend Leon Jacob into thinking
she had been kidnapped by the hitmen he
allegedly hired I sat in a chair in a
warehouse and things have tied my hands
and my feet and put duct tape around my
mouth to make me look as if I had been
kidnapped
Mary Anne Mac McDaniel whose wife was
dating Jacob was another alleged target
he also spoke publicly for the first
time what did you do for them staged my
own death beyond
prosecutors allege Leon Jacob a surgeon
along with his girlfriend at the time
veterinarian Valerie McDaniel offered
two hitmen cartier watches and $20,000
to carry out the murders the discussions
were captured on undercover police video
but the men Jacob and McDaniel were
speaking to les March were not killers
for hire
they were undercover operatives
including Mota's Jose a decorated US
Army veteran recruited by Houston police
were you ever willing to murder anyone
for money no no no I would never do
something like that the other is an
undercover officer we can only identify
as Detective Javier there was
no doubt in my mind that Leon wanted
Megan killed she was under the belief
that I was going to carjack him and I
was going to put a bully in his head
after the fake hitman said the targets
were dead police went to the couple's
Houston high-rise apartment where the
suspects appeared to act surprised
[Music]
officers later ended the charade putting
Jacob and McDaniel in handcuffs for
those who believe I'm looking into the
eyes of essentially a killer what do you
want those people to know I'm innocent
and as a human being and as a physician
that thought of killing somebody else is
just goes against everything in my by
nature your attorney said if you never
met Valerie McDaniel you would not be in
this jail today it's probably true and
the prosecution is likely to wrap up its
case today the defense is expected to
argue leon jacob was pressured by the
undercover agents to order the murders
and in a dramatic twist dr. jacob
himself will take the stand to argue
that point and valerie mcdaniel she took
her own life last year this is such a
chilling story and you've brought it to
us before and i've told you that i went
to school with lianna I knew him pretty
well so I want to ask you about Valerie
in her death because prior to that she
left an audio diary what did she say in
the audio diary she expressed regret for
all of this she had a lot of bad things
to say about her husband alleged
cheating and things that obviously set
her off but she also professed her love
for Leon right here thank you so much